well hello folks here we are back again
session five rolls of faith in the
process of globalization will have a
similar format as we did before except
that we have as you see here three
distinguished guests the panel which is
to say that they're going to do their
presentations for about 12 minutes each
or so have some conversations in between
between them and then we'll take a break
and then we all will be engaged together
in their conversation but before that a
few introductory remarks that I need to
make we have talked about this abiding
significance of fates in the modern
world and world defining character of
globalization processes we mentioned the
globalization entails modernization but
modernization does not necessarily
entail secularization we've developed
and talked about a bit of thesis about
multiple modernity's which is to say
that there is not single way to
modernize but there are multiple ways
and you can have a modernity's than in
religious register that translates that
suggests that in terms of understanding
of globalization a single globalization
that comes in various cultural as well
as religious registers and then we have
talked about relation between
globalization and faiths as the two
weights streets street globalization
shapes and transforms the world of
religions and fades also are brought to
bear about other processes of
globalization now today's session is
kind of transitional one from looking at
the relationship between faith and
globalization more industry descriptive
terms we will be in subsequent sessions
engage particular spheres of life and
engage more normative reflection as well
and here today we are kind of pulling
things together things that we have been
discussing strands of our discussions
looking ahead also tour the ways in
which fades will engage
economy politics international affairs
under the conditions of globalization we
have with us a panel of experts scholars
and a practitioner as well all deeply
immersed in globalization processes and
they'll try to help us do that pull back
things as well as maybe point us also in
direction forward in my introductory
remarks I want to highlight one
important strand of our discussion and
tie to the readings that we had for for
today but to religious leaders John Paul
the second and Dalai Lama arguably they
are among the handful of most
influential religious leaders worldwide
in the past three decades both engage in
these texts globalization processes and
offer kind of an account of self of
social relations and of the good and one
of the things that we emphasized early
on and it came to fore in our
discussions in the first session with
with John Kelsey was how even somebody
like Osama bin Laden who obviously
operates a major terrorist organization
with certain political goals is infused
and motivates a lot of his followers by
certain conception of what the good life
is a certain the standing of the self of
society and also the good obviously now
we have John Paul the second Dalai Lama
it's two quite different folks who are
offering visions of what the good life
is and I wanted I thought it would be
helpful if i could just highlight a bit
of what's going on in some of their
their text and highlight this idea of
notion of the self and the end of the
good and how it engages globalization
processes in their case John Paul the
second globalization and human
solidarity will recall reading those
texts that he starts almost from the
beginning with a very strong affirmation
that a human person is by nature endowed
with universal inviolable and
inalienable
the rights and he makes it as a
universal claim not a culturally
specific one and he makes it as a faith
claim they're in doubt they're not have
not emerged by evolutionary simply by
evolutionary processes as such and then
second information important information
he makes is that justice is rooted in
love love defines fundamentally
relations between humans justices
equality respect for light and the
rights is an essential part of love but
love includes something more than that
that is solidarity also solidarity that
is grounded in mercy and from there it
follows for him a kind of a basic demand
and that demand is globalization there
should be no globalization with
marginalization or globalization without
marginalization human person has to be
at the center of every social project
people should not engage in only seeking
their own good and in particular than
solidarity with mercy attention is paid
to the weakest those who suffer the most
Christian mark distinctive mark of a
Christian is love of the poor the weak
and the suffering and this applies to
all people and everywhere so you see a
certain vision of what the self is what
how social relationships are to be
governed and that's connected with a
critique of globalization processes as
well as a certain form of attempt of
reform now I think similar things you've
got with Dalai Lama going on I think
under the rubric of something like
universal responsibility affirmation one
again it's a general anthropological
claim all human beings desire happiness
and seek to avoid suffering information
to all have equal rights to pursue these
and affirmation 3 altruism and
compassion are as he puts it the
ultimate source of human happiness and
so each needs to learn to work not just
for themselves but also for others for
self other selves humanity nation and so
forth forth and especially in the
context of interdependence working on
behalf of others is part and parcel of
one's own good common goal
and individual good in a sense fall into
one and altruism should be applied in
all spheres of life not just friendship
and family and that is really in his
account a medicine to all social ills
now as we've discussed some of these
things in section some of you thought
well this seems like a little bit too
too thin too rosy I'd too religious for
the kind of hard-nosed realities of the
world in which we in which we live and I
think one of the challenges that we are
facing is how to connect this
overarching perspect religious
overarching perspective lives live on
life many of which are centered around
the person centered around the
decentering in a sense of person away
from the self to the larger community to
the ultimate reality how do we connect
it with realities of the world today
which seem to be so much in its default
mode self-referential says self-obsessed
and where it looks to us as if
individual of peers as I think Philip
Roth has said as black as black holes of
self-absorption now now that's a bit bit
excessive to put it in those in those
terms but in that caricature a lot of us
recognize well maybe a bit of ourselves
and less charitable than we are also
quite a bit of some other folks that we
can think of but it is it is a
fundamental question that we are facing
I think how do overarching
interpretations of life religious
overarching interpretations of life
which may claims to what it means to be
a human and live fulfilled human lives
how do they intersect with the processes
of globalization in the life in the
modern world it's this that is going to
be brought to bear in the sense in the
future sessions that we have about
economy about politics about
international relations from the
religious perspective and it's there
also that possible transformations
possible pushbacks are going to happen
in terms of globalization processes now
I wanted to put this on
table simply for us to keep in mind how
in these two very important cases
overarching interpretations of life
function I wanted to or we don't have
the time but I wanted to do is also to
analyze for you the speech at the UN or
avek medina giant which is a very
interesting case which i think poses for
us are interesting in interesting issue
to explore I think one of one of you who
is not present here Rachel talk to me
about that speech recall she was the one
who originally sent us a copy of it and
she said you know I had this strange
experience of agreeing completely with
the first part of his speech where he
spells out his religious vision but
totally disagree with the second part of
his speech where he applies this in a
sense to international relations now
that too is a very interesting case in
point that we can think and reflect of
how do these overarching interpretations
of life and claims that we make about
human beings in their relations how do
they then translate into very concrete
assessments of what's going on in the
world today and that you have this kind
of a jarring case for most of us is I
think a very very challenging question
that we need to face I will not continue
much longer since we have our
distinguished panel here what I'll do
I'll introduce them and then I'll let
them run and less they run too far then
I'll stuff them we have with us Jose
Casanova is a professor of sociology at
Georgetown University and senior fellow
at the Berkeley Center you have read
some of his some of his works there are
extraordinary even in the summary form
that you received them in those articles
I consider him to be the the foremost
interpretive of religion in our
globalized world and it's a great
pleasure to having here true leader in
that in that field I can rattle off a
good deal of other stuff from his from
his CV but you can find that very easily
it's
in on the other internet next to him
sitting is alarming solemn Willis James
professor of mission and world
Christianity and professor of history at
Yale al-amin is one of those
extraordinary Pierre completely lawmen
is one of those extraordinary
intellectuals and interpreters of the
Christian tradition who has fertile mind
creative are able to see things that for
most of us remained a remain of pagan
till he has pointed his finger to it and
we say ha that's exactly right and of
his ability to interpret what's going on
especially in the world of Christianity
for the rest of the world is absolutely
extraordinary pleasure to have him here
pleasure to have him also as my
colleague and then sitting next to
al-amin is my good friend Timothy
Collins he's the founder and senior
director and chief executive officer of
ripple world holdings and holds BA in
philosophy and is an extraordinarily
able amateur philosopher who has also
started doing PhD work in philosophy the
major institution in this in this
country and has read stuff that many of
us academics haven't in terms of key
philosophical philosophical works he not
only represent here for us kind of the
world of international business where he
is a major actor but also in that
capacity interacts with politicians from
all sorts of backgrounds for wide
variety of countries and he sits or
shall I say move at a place from which
he is able as I think no other to to
assess the intersection of a faith and
values that are based on faith and
globalization processes and besides I
think he's one of the smartest people
that I know one of the things
no so so so just just to just to make
sure that you don't now see team because
the door I think we want we want to have
a very frank frank conversation here
Frank and comradely exchanges that
sounds like in the Communist era that
that was really cold that was the cold
word that everybody left with a black
eye the meeting the day of which they
have been a been apart but since we do
want to address some of the issues that
are even significant as we speak now our
relationship between financial crisis
and of today and values tim has asked
for his comments to be completely off
the record your pants are off you don't
tell you don't write to any of your of
your friends emails about what has
transpired and so forth we want to hurt
our congressmen are you gonna write
right well that's right are you enemies
for that matter right but I I ask that
you honor honor this and I hope that
this would stimulate our discussion put
us on the edge of our seats and engage
issues that profoundly engages
existentially the world as a whole in
terms of the discussions that we are
having an issues that we're dealing with
in this course this is where I stop and
this is where Professor Casanova starts
well thank you very much it's a pleasure
and an honor to be here these one of the
courses that we professors would like to
take so you're good you are clearly
fortunately chalice again this is one of
the corseting with you what we always
say we assume you read the papers I know
you did so I don't have even to try to
summarize my arguments I'm going
actually to bring something new to the
table in terms the discussion gloves off
right so we have to be very frank and
polemical no I mean
I mean we must avoid thinking of this
process that were religion before these
traditional things then comes
modernization and globalization and then
you have religions responding to it
being transformed by it etc is much more
complicated than that I would like to
argue that globalization should be
understood also is three simultaneous
process going on in addition to
everything you've heard about
globalization there is a process of a
globalization of what Charles Taylor
calls the imminent frame there is a
globalization of world religions
religions are themselves the products of
globalization religious we know them
today and as we talk about him today
you've heard a whole literature and the
invention of Creed I Hinduism the
invention of Confucianism the embed the
Protestant Buddhism all of these world
religions and even Islam today in
Catholicism our product of these dynamic
relations between all of them between
the first parts of secularization the
imminent frame and how this religions
are transformed and third there is a
global price of sacral is asian going on
the sack realization of humanity the
sack religion of human rights and the
interesting question is how these three
processes are interrelated and create
different dynamics in each place with
things that traditions religious
traditions that existed already before
this process beginning with the fact
that the whole process of secularization
in the West itself is intrinsically
related with a transformation of the
Christian tradition then becomes
globalized and appears to the nun west
as Christianization and then the dynamic
of how the other religions respond to
this Christian secular modernization is
itself fascinating so secularization in
Mallen frame yes the globalization of a
concepts of view of the universe which
we all share today basically determined
by our modern science and technology
this has been globalized very few people
questioned these today the globalization
of structures of society characterized
by markets
it's and public as fierce again they
take different forms but less nothing
that Chinese capitalism and American
capitalism and Indian capitalism are the
same they're very different the same
thing that Indian democracy American
democracy in France democracy are very
different so even those things that we
consider secular modern global are very
different local context that's why we
talk of multiple modalities and then
secularization of the buffers of this
individual self individualism in the way
in which Taylor talks about it together
with this process you have this
formation of a system of global world
religions each of them and the one hand
reconstructing defining its own
particular uniqueness bisa be the
secular modernity and be savvy one
another and at the same time that they
defend these uniqueness they present
themselves to the rest of the world is
the universal solution form of humanity
you have a dynamic in which is religion
claims to be unique and different from
each of them but also the universal one
for everybody is the dynamic which is an
extremely interesting how it is
happening today at every level and how
the interaction between all these
religions today between Islam and
Hinduism between within Judaism and
Christianity cetera is as important as
the relation each of them have to this
thing we call secular modernity in third
sack realization cyclization it was
during the founder of my discipline who
argues that the old gods are buying a
new gods are not yet born but the new
religion will be the count of humanity
the sack realization of the individual
well this is what our circulation of
Human Rights moves but again in we are
less talk of jump all the second here
you have the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights basically the Universal
Declaration of the Rights of Man by the
french revolutionary assembly the
Constituent Assembly the Catholic Church
reacting this is heresy this goes
against God against the church and for
150 years the Catholic Church denounced
in the discourse of human rights and
then in the 50s the Catholic Church
adapt in this discourse example the
second becoming
he calls himself the fencer Albanese the
defender of the sacred human person how
they all guards have been revitalized by
becoming the carriers of the new guards
on how the Old Religion conform and
Davis us present is the most universal
religion of humanity is of course one of
the mass passing interesting fascinating
questions but of course this means that
each of these processes also provokes
the need for the religious traditions to
redefine to reformulate themselves
visible this process visa be secular
institutions of science market states in
public spheres media Sarah visa be this
concept of global system of religions
let's call it global denominationalism
and this I think what is going on today
in the same way the United States create
this system of internal
denominationalism where x is religion
claims to be the true authentic religion
but a process of mutual recognition of
one another takes place not regulated by
the state not regulated by law but
nonetheless approach of mutual
recognition first only among Protestant
religions The Deuce and the Catholics at
first were not part of the system
eventually Judaism and Catholicism
become part of the American system of
denominational denominationalism into
the Islam and Hinduism and Buddhism are
becoming American religious in this
sense and you have this model of if you
wish all the world religions becoming
American here in the United States and
then the process by which the same a
similar process is taking place at a
global level not we have complete there
were a lot of conflict between
Protestants and Catholics churches were
burned people were killed nativism
anti-catholic nativism was very strong
for decades in American history and so
the same the issue of I'll be finished
in two minutes the issue of u nless the
issue of because I'm get out of a moment
I would rather have I would rather have
the students asking questions in
challenging us the issue of the extent
to which then each religious traditions
has to deal with all these three
well processes in obviously all our
theories of religion where established
and the base of the experience of
Protestant Christianity this was the
sauce best social science of religion
was based originally on the study of
protest angry sorry Kath ilysm was never
studied seriously for me of course it
was because I became I came from
Catholicism and I was a part of this
process of catholica journa mentor with
modernity in vatican two and how it was
transformed through the transformation
from what was primarily a European kind
of tradition to becoming much more a
global nine European tradition and then
how this is happening the transformation
of all other religious traditions in
this sense so we should avoid
dichotomies of religious and the secular
we should avoid the notion of a simple
process of secularization against which
religions react which is much of the
theories of religious fundamentalism are
based on these categories and try to
understand those pricey processes are
much more complex everywhere and
especially that even within the ways we
have to accept multiple modalities
within the West because only then the
issue of multiple modalities outside
becomes viable is a category because if
not you have a category of the secular
modern West and then the other we
somehow are different we have to avoid
because even within the West American
modernity friends modernity are very
very different in many many respects so
thank you thank you
it's yours now lobbying the floor is
zero I thought Tim was good here are
giving some of my minutes to you too
well thank you very much for including
me in this mirrors love I have to say
that being a historian of religion
coming here feels like being a wet hand
at a cocktail party I prepared i was
given instructions that we only had 12
minutes to speak and so I am I went to a
boarding school and time is like you
know something I my boogie man sort of
fear before the hammer comes down so i
thought i put my comments down on paper
and that way be able to sort of use the
time to our mutual advantage faith and
globalization and i thought of ways of
summarizing my remarks and i thought
well maybe two words will summarize what
i what i want to say making connections
I suppose it would be appropriate in
this setting and given my own academic
predilections to open with the
observations of Adam Smith on the
springs of globalization in his day and
the consequences of global enterprise he
wrote in 1776 a date that we don't know
in the United States in his wealth of
nations that the two events that have
altered the cause of global trade and
history were the discovery of the new
world and the passage to the East Indies
via the Cape of Good Hope the cutting of
the Suez Canal we should recall a
hundred years into the future Adam Smith
said that by uniting the most distant
part of the world and by and i quote
enabling them to leave one another's
wants to increase when a lot of
enjoyments and to encourage one
another's industry the general tendency
would seem to be beneficial
but whether beneficial or not the world
has changed irreversibly thanks to those
two facts in the course of the 19th
century Europe strengthened its maritime
dominance as the sea lanes replaced the
overland routes as the major channels of
the global trade and commerce it's a
very significant shift very significant
change the Seawolves call them in
history took over from the hounds of the
global economic system the hounds here
being the Muslim carriers who control
for 700 years the overland routes from
Spain the market sub-saharan Africa to
India and China the question of
intercultural traffic and connections in
these early centuries has you not be
surprised to hear interested me greatly
you cannot go say from the geographical
dictionary of Ali accout writing between
12 12 and 12 29 to his Christian
counterpart like Marco Polo without
feeling adult the Muslim geographer has
a keen eye for detail with fidelity to
standards of factual representation
while on the other hand Marco Polo or
the person hiding behind that name has a
weakness for the incredulous and
fantastic with later Muslim writers of
the 14th century such as Eden battuta
and i'll do the graters of them all in
the cultural engagement assumes a
vigorous form the prestige on complex of
medieval Christian writers is strikingly
absent in Muslim sources now I do not
deny pretend to deny the fact that some
Muslim writers hell their nose while
describing societies they considered
inferior including Europe by the way the
closest we get in the West to the high
standards of Muslim writers is with the
Franciscan explorations of the art and
culture Mongolia and China between 1250
and 1350 that competes a thing favorably
with Islamic accounts it's fascinating
to think that is only in 1999 that we
had a book by Lauren Arnold giving us
vast riches of this Franciscan
exploration of Chinese culture and art
the Franciscans were explicit about how
faith helped them to connect and
understand the world with moral
accountability we may observe that in
culture contact there always is an
implicit certain comparative evaluation
as L Brunner the great islamic
philosopher and scientist pointed out we
connect with the unknown and the
unfamiliar only within the frame of the
loan and the familiar if you believe as
early muslim writers and their catholic
contemporaries did that God created the
world then it is relatively
straightforward to venture into that
world with the idea that God is equally
to be found there if only we have eyes
to see I cannot make much more of this
viewpoint here regrettably beyond just
referring to it and moving on for me
however its bearing on adam smith's
observation is clear adam smith is right
to contend that the global process has
strong foundations in economic
enterprise and the communications
revolution that was then spanning the
world yet he also says that the
proximity of the global trade and
commerce had had deleterious
consequences for what he called and i
quote the natives both of the East and
the West Indies he did not say perhaps
he did not see how the west and the
Muslim world would be thrown together as
a result of those discoveries and this
is where I think religion has offered
another paradigm for inter cultural
engagement by staking its reputation on
the god of one humanity the greatest
maritime Explorer
for the age of Vasco de Gama was
actually a Muslim scholar Chinese maje
who lived in china in the Ming Dynasty
and he traveled 70,000 miles by sea from
China to the coast of East Africa and
back again and on his way stopped in
salon Sri Lanka and there he raised a
monument to the three guards the Buddha
the Christian God and to Allah a
remarkable example of ecumenical
sensitivity and understanding so
religion does offer in my view a
paradigm for intercultural engagement
now it would be a caricature to say that
religion has been a force for good
everywhere that's not the case as we
know very well from the history of Latin
America far from it but I do say that it
gave early inter-cultural pioneers a
basis for genuine encounter however
uneven the record here are few examples
as early pioneers of in the cultural
exploration Muslim travelers and
geographers we're in specific respects
quite outstanding for their attitudes of
intercultural curiosity local
sensitivity breadth of horizon and
historical balance an obscure Muslim
visitor to china in 851 already during
the abbasid caliphate who also visited
india and therefore had a kind of
comparative perspective right admiring
Lee if a trace to romantically of the
social standards China achieved for its
people he notes that the government of
China provides health care for the needy
which is why China is healthier than
India he says and I quote from this
anonymous writer one never sees a blind
man a [ __ ] or an infirm person there
whereas many of them are found in India
he testifies whether poor or rich young
adult the Chinese attained a high level
of literacy he writes in the towns
schools are established and
dowd from public funds teachers are
supported of state expense the
government maintains a cost-of-living
index and intervenes to cushion people
against violence spikes of price
inflation now it is relevant here to
refer to even battuta one more time
while on a surgeon in cydia Martha in
southern morocco even battuta discovered
that his host in Morocco was the brother
of a man he met many years before in
western China on the christian side we
have the accounts of the Italian
Franciscans fry or a Doric of pordenone
in China between 12 23 and 12 27 and
Bishop Andrew of Perugia who wrote from
china in 1326 and he indulged a
comparable admiration for China without
again Marco Polo's fabrications and
omissions suggesting how religious
sensibility was an asset in
intercultural exploration a striking
example of such cultural sensitive
sensitivity being able to swim out
personal handicaps and still to remain
faithful to the historical record is the
account of the Portuguese Pereira who
was in china between 1349 and 1352 he
spent by the way three years in prison
in China and in spite of that hardship
wrote about a knife caught him we poor
strangers brought before them before the
Chinese might say justly and in truth
that they did bear with her so patiently
that they caused us to wonder knowing
specially how little any advocate or
judge is want in our own country to bear
with us so China's treatment of
foreigners he said compares very
favorably with European treatment of
foreigners eyes on the clock
I should not be understood here are
suggesting that antiquity is the escape
route for anyone disenchanted with
contemporary inter cultural challenges
because the legend doesn't lessen I want
to draw here if that religion has been
able to transcend the barriers and the
limitations of geography and economic
self-interest and that lesson if we
choose we can apply to our own age as I
pointed out in my TLS article on the
return of religion that was widespread
consternation about the sudden explosion
of religion beginning in the waning
decades of the 20th century in part
because neither the rapid collapse of
the colonial empires no the surge of
nationalist movements have been able had
been the decisive setback for religion
that everyone expected and in part also
because the acceleration of
secularization had not brought about the
end of religion as Casanova's just
reminded us consequently religious
resurgence has complicated conventional
calculations about the new world order
would religious radicalism I complicated
an intractable problem for international
security the Christian resurgence is
part of the complex nature of the global
awakening and its interconnected
challenges in strong and weak states
alike the awakening has continued to
search an alarmed Chinese official not
so long ago suggested for the reason
strangling the baby while it is still in
the crib while a Marxist African leader
favored the artichoke method of
repression by peeling away overlapping
ancillary Christian organizations and
agencies before attacking the core of
the church hierarchy only the
intervention of faith-based
organizations averted the prospects of
ultimate despair in this case and I'm
thinking here of Ethiopia I favor a
different approach you
relieved to hear Islamic radicalism for
instance is not because of poverty
isolation or ignorance as Thomas
Friedman has argued in several new york
times up at aces I think in calling for
a Sharia State radicalism like Singapore
in the Second World War is pointing it's
heavy artillery in the wrong direction
none of the founders of classical
Islamic law for instance was a paid a
client of the state they were in fact
all of them conscientious objectors
second the radicals are mistaken in
their view that the modern West is the
reason for the decline of Islam it was
the British authorities for example who
on a systematic basis sponsored the
collection of Arabic legal documents and
manuscripts the founding of schools of
law and language with the libraries to
go with them staffing them with trained
magistrates and providing a regular
revenue stream from taxes and levies to
pay for these services as a consequence
Muslim magistrates presided over the
revitalization of Islamic legal
scholarship by guiding the whole process
through one of its most expansive
periods in Africa we have the work of
Sonoma and Anderson who summarizes an
India we have Muhammad Phi Z outlines of
Anglo Muhammad law is the kind of
special hybrid law in East Java the
Dutch achieved the same results met the
last Governor of the East Java very old
man in those days in his 80s from the
plas and he was very much you might call
an Islamic activists a robust hybrid
legal tradition developed encouraging
contemporary Muslim legal scholars today
to argue that the new legal situation is
unimpeachably closer to classical
Islamic law than the ideas of today's
radicals the lesson I draw from this
again is that the western encounter
constitutes a crucial corridor of
the cultural exchange and of the
transmission of mutually beneficial
ideas and values and in that respect
legal reform may hold the key I believe
to the islamization of society a form of
civil agency without the Mandate of the
state I would like in conclusion to make
a symmetrical argument about the
Christian awakening religious renewal on
the present scale and is really
phenomenal what has happened since
nineteen sixty in nineteen sixty eighty
percent of the Christian world was
European and North American 2008 only
less than thirty five percent of the
Christian world is European and North
American within forty-five years forty
eight years it's been extraordinary
shift um so I want to make that argument
that it has implications for the affairs
of organized society civil society what
Tocqueville calls the principle of
organization is likely to assume if I
greater role in this new environment
with education the catalyst for issues
of social change and for engagement with
new global forces the organization
called transformational business network
TBN for example is committed and I quote
from its manual to using business to
bring spiritual and physical
transformation to the world's poor the
founding director of TBN is dr. Kim tan
a Malaysian Chinese now based in Britain
who has worked with Brian gif Griffiths
Brown Griffiths was the architect for
Margaret Thatcher's privatization in the
UK and Kim has his headquarters in
Guildford just outside London and he
also owns happens to own a game Park in
the Eastern Cape that he runs as a
business but with this social focus of
providing employment skills training as
well
capital and shares for workers recruited
from South Africa's very large
unemployment pool it is vindication of
the theme of Richard who guards 1971 BBC
wreath lectures entitled only connect
and culture and communication who got
wrote we can connect we have to collect
not by the solemnities of the most of
most attempts at international
understanding but by a fully phased and
felt realization of common qualities the
ribs he says of the universal human
gramma if as Malcolm bribery had said
society is a way for us to speak to one
another then I'm not sure that there is
a more effective engine for making the
connection than voluntary civil agency
both national and international and here
i should just lift for show and tell the
book by brand Griffiths and Kim tan
called fighting poverty through
enterprise and a little brochure which
describes the work of TBN and Kim is by
the way in touch with the Nelson Mandela
Foundation as well as with many human
rights groups based in New York and
London I mean and Washington just to
show you i think the reach of these new
sort of force of global christianity
making connections through someone like
kim tan thank you